huit ans de réclusion pour le jeune alex
et la cour d'assises reconnaît sa
culpabilité mais ce verdict présent de
sa du réquisitoire est mitigé
insatisfaisant selon la défense
demain élections régionales et
cantonales près de 39 millions
d'électeurs appelés aux urnes mode
d'emploi de ce scrutin à un seul tour
pour les régionales et à deux tours pour
les cantonales
ouverture de la pêche à la truite d'un
peu partout en france 2 millions
d'adeptes pour ce soir ou ce loisir qui
se présente sous les meilleurs auspices
grâce à un hiver pluvieux vente aux
enchères des objets cultes des kennedy
aux états unis dans les placards du
président souvenirs souvenirs mode avec
les défilés de trois grands maîtres du
prêt-à-porter moins baroque mois
provoque gaultier lacroix miyake des
filous l épuré et des matières jolie
madame monsieur bonsoir je vous le dise
en titre la cour d'assises des yvelines
a condamné à huit ans de prison le jeune
alexis reconnaissant ainsi sa
culpabilité pour les six meurtres de
l'ancien une condamnation très en
dessous du réquisitoire de l'avocat
général qui demandait la peine maximale
pour un mineur une sanction qui appelle
un certain nombre de questions puisque
dès hier soir en parlait de sanctions
mitigé de demi-mesure s'étoffant le
verdict du doute pour les avocats de la
défense tirer curtet philippe rey qu'est
ce que la mère d'alexis doit comprendre
de ce verdict d'un côté la cour lui dit
qu'elle ne croit pas son fils lorsque
celui ci affirme que les six meurtres
sont l'oeuvre d'un règlement de compte
de la mafia roots mais de l'autre les
jurés le condamne à huit ans de
réclusion pour avoir tué six membres de
sa famille comme elle
les trois avocats d'alexis ont du mal à
analyser cette décision
pour quelqu'un est innocent huit ans est
inacceptable pour quelqu'un est coupable
mais temps c'est un jugement de salomon
entre les deux un vraisemblance la cour
a donc choisi celle qui lui est apparue
la moins invraisemblable car alexis dans
un premier temps avait reconnu les six
meurt avant de se rétracter
mais la cour a été visiblement très
troublé par les hypothèses russe
ce verdict montre que le débat fut
probablement abr entre les jurés on se
retrouve une espèce de point quidditch
tant qu' évidemment pour quelqu'un qui
en parlent ils sont innocents c'est pas
quelque chose de l'acceptable alors sur
la lorraine fils doute faut aller
jusqu'au bout de mes fessiers douter
c'est l'acquittement au bénéfice du
doute à marcher à mi chemin une peine
qui plonge ses proches ses avocats dans
la perplexité ne pas aller en cassation
c'est d'accepter la culpabilité d'alexis
se pourvoir c'est prendre le risque
d'une peine beaucoup plus lourde
alors qu'avec le jeu des remises de
peine il sortira dans deux ans au plus
tard pour la famille donc le sentiment
d'une condamnation au bénéfice du doute
en quelque sorte patrick pas des ex
suspect numéro un dans le meurtre de
caroline dickinson est innocenté grâce à
des tests adn
ce sdf pourrait devenir l'un des témoins
clés de l'enquète il affirme du mois
avoir reconnu l'homme dont le portrait
robot est diffusée depuis le 13 février
son témoignage est pris très au sérieux
par le juge van ruymbeke chargé de la
faire revivre les cieux michel hiver
l'ex suspect numéro un est devenu un
témoin clé en voyant le portrait robot
diffusé dans la presse il ya quelques
semaines un tri spadea cru reconnaître
un homme qui l'avait croisé non loin de
pleine fougères quelques jours avant le
meurtre et le viol de caroline dickinson
un individu qui circulait dans une 4l
blanche et qui avait dit il tenté de
l'écraser
mais s'est arrêté
10-3 méthode si il s'est retourné et
c'est la bombe a jamais eu autant ils
ont des deux classes par patrice pas d
alors préféré en parler d'abord à son
avocat maître gonzalez de gaspard qui a
immédiatement pris rendez vous avec le
juge van ruymbeke
convaincu de l'importance du témoignage
de son client on peut penser qu'il ya
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
qui vient de se dégager
puisque je connais pas d c'est un homme
sérieux et s'il se dit qu'il peut le
reconnaître
pratiquement nous pouvons nous fier de
fait cette rencontre pas dès on avait
déjà parlé au cours de sa garde à vue
aux gendarmes qui s'étaient contentés de
le noter sur procès verbal
aujourd'hui l'ex routard ne souhaite une
chose que l'on retrouve au plus vite le
véritable assassin
plus tôt on trouvera le coupable ba ba
des gens parlent pas mal des gens je me
serais plus comment je sais plus trop
quoi
pas pour jean g20 certains il prend
encore coupable cette lan est un seul
les tests génétiques ont permis
d'innocenter patrice pas des des tests
qui serviront peut-être à confondre le
coupable si la piste du portrait robot
abouti à saint malo la cellule spéciale
de la gendarmerie reçoit aujourd'hui
encore plusieurs dizaines d'appels
quotidiens
c'est en visionnant une cassette vidéo
destiné à la prévention des abus sexuels
que des enfants de cours préparatoire
ont formulé les agissements à caractère
pédophile de leurs instituteurs l'année
précédente la faire se déroule près du
mans l'instituteur âgé de 51 ans et à la
réputation parfaite jusque là a été
écroué arnaud boutet champagne mouton
devant le panneau d'affichage de l'école
les parents d'élèves viennent timidement
chercher quelques réponses à toutes les
questions qu'ils se posent dès lundi ils
seront pris en charge par un psychologue
parler le besoin se fait sentir afin de
comprendre ce qui se passait dans l'une
de ses classes de la maternelle
comment jean-pierre courte abc l'instit
comme on l'appelle at il pu commettre
ces attouchements sur quatorze enfants
âgés de cinq à sept ans
barbara joue dans le parc des érables en
visionnant ce film de prévention des
abus sexuels
plusieurs élèves du cours préparatoire
ont alors dénoncé leur ancien
instituteur le travail que nous avons
entrepris un travail de prévention et
d'information sur ces choses-là courage
on s'attendait à tout sauf au fait
d'avoir une telle révélation
plusieurs parents réagissent par cette
pétition pour imposer la diffusion du
film de prévention dans toutes les
écoles à sagelat ocp à 6 ans
inconsciemment il lance des paroles qui
sont vraies mais ben inconsciemment
trafford
on a des histoires comme ça et au cepex
découvre derrière les barreaux de sa
cellule jean-pierre courte abc a reconnu
une partie des faits il conteste
néanmoins les accusations de viol à
l'encontre de quatre enfants
à 52 ans ce grand père instituteur
travaillez beaucoup avec ses élèves sur
la parole l'expression pour apprendre à
tout dire même quand ça ne va pas la
sécurité en question à moins de trois
mois de la coupe du monde de football
les organisateurs ont testé hier soir à
toulouse leur dispositif un scénario
grandeur nature et dans des conditions
réelles pour ajuster répéter les
méthodes de sécurité dont on en charge
professionnels et bénévoles le reportage
fait du lycée riasq didier rancoeur tu
veux on reçoit différencier ils sont
plus de 200 certains d'entre eux sont
des passionnés du ballon rond
d'autres n'ont encore jamais mis les
pieds dans un stade mais pour tous une
même motivation
c'est un peu un aboutissement de venir à
la coupe du monde
j'ai tout le temps on fait du bénévolat
non mais pour moi c'est un coup dur pour
cette soirée test lors du match toulouse
lyon il faudra appliquer les consignes à
la lettre les deux tiers des stadiers
sont des bénévoles étudiants pour la
plupart leur mission accueillir les
supporters et les surveiller pendant le
match
en cas de problème leur chef d'equipe
qui eux sont des professionnels de la
sécurité prenne le relais personnes
étaient restées isolées rend compte au
pc sécurité qui nous demande d'aller
voir deux ou trois soirs et la police
restent à l'extérieur du stade et
n'interviendra que si la situation
dégénère premier contact avec les
supporters et premier problème des
drapeaux avec des manches en bois
le schéma est pour enlever si tu veux
l'animation du stade qui est fait
chargera paul super après intervention
des responsables du club de toulouse
les drapeaux font leur entrée dans le
stade vraiment il y avait aussi une
différente d'une porte à l'autre donc
donc c'est c'est leur coup d'essai
il faut les laisser se roder pour céline
cette première prise de contact c'est un
avant goût de ce qui l'attend pendant la
coupe du monde
et pourtant hier le stade était à moitié
vide et l'ambiance bon enfant en juin
prochain
les stadiers trouveront face à eux des
supporters plus difficile à contrôler
près de 39 millions d'électeurs sont
appelés à voter demain pour les
élections régionales et le premier tour
des cantonales 17 mille candidats
répartis dans 26 régions se présente aux
élections régionales le taux de
participation reste l'une des
incertitudes de ce scrutin élections en
mode d'emploi j'évite humbert d'abord
les élections régionales tout le monde
vote c'est-à-dire 38 millions
d'électeurs dans les 22 régions de
métropole
on ne se rendra aussi en une seule fois
un tour unique car le scrutin a lieu à
la proportionnelle
le conseil régional élu pour six ans à
d'importants pouvoirs dans deux grands
domaines
d'abord l'éducation site à la région
qu'il revient aujourd'hui de construire
d'entretenir les lycées de financer la
formation professionnelle mais aussi une
partie de l'enseignement supérieur
ensuite les transports nouvelle
autoroute ou nouvelle ligne de tgv
les grandes infrastructures sont
décidées conjointement par l'état et par
la région avec la décentralisation les
présidents de conseils régionaux sont
devenus des personnalités politiques
puissante deuxième scrutin demain les
élections cantonales tous les
départements sont concernés sauf paris
mais on ne vote que dans les cantons
renouvelables c'est à dire la moitié
d'entre eux ces élections là sont au
scrutin majoritaire avec un deuxième
tour dimanche prochain là où il ya
ballottage
les conseils généraux sont donc les
assemblées du département ont de
nombreuses compétences par exemple en
matière de santé et d'action sociale les
campagnes de dépistage ou de vaccination
les dispensaires les centres de
protection maternelle et infantile sont
à leur charge
logiquement l'entretien des routes
départementales leur incombe aussi côté
budget celui des départements est
souvent plus élevé que celui des régions
cantonales régionales
deux élections et beaucoup de
prétendants plus de 26000 candidat se
présente demain une france 2 consacrera
toute la soirée demain dès 19h40 aux
résultats de ces élections sous la
houlette de daniel bilalian aux côtés
d'arlette chabot et d'alain duhamel
toute la rédaction est mobilisé
duplex en direct de toutes les régions
analyses commentaires invité sur le
plateau
la soirée électorale s'interrompra à
22h15 et reprendra diminue journée
nationale aujourd'hui du secours
populaire avec un appel à la générosité
pour aider les plus démunis parmi ses
différentes actions je vous propose de
suivre l'exemple de la réinsertion par
le théâtre organisé par cet organisme
une initiative originale exemplaire
puisqu'elle permet aux plus défavorisés
de passer de l'ombre à la lumière
reportage à clermont ferrand
marie-hélène bono jean-louis melun deux
rôles d'acteur ils ont été embauchés par
le secours populaire pour jouer sur
scène alors que ce n'est pas leur métier
ils bénéficient d'un contrat emploi
solidarité
le théâtre est ici un moyen d'insertion
yolande assez ap devant deux divorcés
sans emploi elle n'a pas la garde de ses
enfants
aujourd'hui comme comédienne elle gagne
2800 francs par mois mais surtout elle a
retrouvé ses moyens pour affronter le
monde du travail
quant à la semaine prochaine je vais
faire une formation de l'informatique en
comptabilité qui va compléter mon cap2
vendeur
yolande a réappris à travailler en
équipe avec des règles des horaires
autre exemple marc titulaire d'un deug
de lettres
il est depuis peu régisseur eu un petit
peu le responsable quant à celui entre
le secours populaire et les comédiens
qui sont avec nous marc bien connu le
chômage les problèmes financiers le
surendettement mais s'il a vécu
l'exclusion c'est surtout en raison de
son homosexualité avec son ami il a dû
quitter sa ville son appartement pour
lui aujourd'hui travailler dans la
troupe c'est plus qu'un emploi ça fait
du bien d'aider les autres aussi parce
que c'est un dieu mais galère mais
maintenant avec ma petite expérience je
peux aider les autres à la fin du mois
il aura un emploi jeunes payés au smic
son rêve c'est de continuer à travailler
et à vie
dans le milieu culturel de se retrouver
tous ensemble de faire une répète
d'aller manger ensemble c'est toute la
vie artistique qui me plaît il était
demandeur d'emploi de solidarité
aujourd'hui le but du spectacle et de
les mettre dedans la lumière pour faire
voir qu'ils sont pas que six klues jean
fait que ces sont des hommes et des
femmes à part entière et qu'ils ont des
savoirs et que on peut aussi les
regarder et qu' ils savent aussi offrir
des choses votre maurice pour toujours
j'ai notamment à lire j'ai pas tout
compris et pleurer et vous pensez ça
peut vous aider par exemple dans un
métier comme vendeur dix ans que le
monde de la vente est un possiblement du
théâtre devant public qui s'appelle
clients ils ne passeront sans doute pas
leur vie sur les planches
mais cette aventure sur scène leur
permet de voir l'avenir autrement qu'on
situation d'échec
depuis plusieurs semaines les
entreprises commencent de négocier des
accords sur les 35 heures les cadres
sont au même titre que d'autres salariés
concernés par ces nouvelles dispositions
mais considérant qu'ils dépassent bien
souvent l'horaire légal du temps de
travail qui sortent un véritable casse
tête que nous explique que sébastien
vibert eyene gicquel qui se sont rendus
chez thomson alain bonnet n'est pas le
genre de cadre à compter ses heures
mais depuis quelques années comme indy
la charge de travail a explosé stress
fatigue frustration il a fait le calcul
45 eur minimum en moyenne par semaine et
c'est moins que beaucoup de ses
collègues
on nous dit ben vous avez des objectifs
réalisés pour les réaliser débrouillez
vous débrouillez vous alors quand on dit
ben oui mais j'en fais plus c'est votre
choix nous répond ou aller voir ailleurs
les cadres travaillent trop conclusions
de nombreux enquête de l'inspection du
travail comme ici chez thomson en mars
96 une inspectrice y constate des
dépassements systématique d'horaires
elle invite la direction à réorganiser
le travail pour respecter l'heure légale
à 39 heures l'inspectrice revient un an
et demi plus tard mais rien n'a changé
elle relève huit mille infractions
cette fois ci c'est le procès verbal
thomson risque une très lourde amende
pendant des années des années les cadres
ont travaillé 44 46 48 heures sans
heures supplémentaires payées sans repos
compensateur et en fait c'était
totalement illégale il y a deux mois
direction et syndicats thompson ont
quand même signé un accord pointeuse
hebbadj pour tout le monde
trente huit heures 30 hebdomadaires
maximum et 80 embauches prévues pour
compenser l'accord a fait l'effet d'une
bombe
de nombreux pdg n'apprécie guère les
contrôles des inspecteurs du travail et
l'ont fait savoir
du coup martine aubry ministre de
tutelle des inspecteurs leur a indiqué
fermement que les contrôles sur le temps
de travail des cadres n'était pas une
priorité douzaine intempestifs ne serait
pas toléré les règles d'ordre public de
durée maximale du travail ne sont plus
du tout respecté et ça nous semble
difficilement admissible en tant
qu'inspecteur du travail d'accepter ça
surtout qu'on est chargé de faire
appliquer ses textes
si le temps de travail n'est pas prend
alors la réduction du temps de travail
sera une fiction les syndicats
d'inspecteurs ont écrit au ministre et
menacent de faire grève pour beaucoup il
faut d'abord respecter les 39 heures
avant de passer à 35 et ne pas flouer
les cadres si on nous demande de
travailler moins en théorie
sans modifier notre façon d'organiser le
travail aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passera demain et bien
on va travailler autant peut-être comme
une ére - et on résoudra absolument pas
ni dans le problème de surcharge
martine aubry n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer publiquement sur cette
question à quelques semaines du vote de
la loi des 35 heures dans un lourd
climat de défiance chez les cadres le
vatican s'apprête à publier lundi un
document sur l'holocauste et la
responsabilité de l'église catholique un
texte attendu et promis depuis des
années ce document interviendrait
quelques mois après la déclaration de
repentance des évêques français parce
que le vatican ne semblerait pas prêt un
vrai mea culpa marque met en oeuvre pour
en finir avec le silence de l'église
catholique pendant l'holocauste
jean paul ii va engager le catholicisme
dans un texte sur sa responsabilité face
à la communauté juive mondiale
jean paul ii est né à wadowice est à
quelques km h
persécutés par les nazis contraints à la
clandestinité
le futur pape savait ce qui se passait à
auschwitz il s'est longtemps reproché
son silence mais l'homme qui a permis la
béatification d'edith stein morte à
auschwitz poursuit autre chose qu'un
projet personnel il veut dit-il purifier
l'église avant le troisième millénaire
en 1987 jean paul ii avait promis qu'il
établirait la responsabilité du
christianisme dans l'antisémitisme
lundi il assumera au moins une partie de
cette promesse réitérée en 1993 lors du
rétablissement des relations
diplomatiques avec israël les juifs
souhaite un mea culpa de l'église
catholique
il n'est pas sûr que le pape y soit prêt
ainsi il a toujours défendu pie xii
accusé d'être silencieux face à
l'holocauste commis par les nazis il
n'est pas sûr que le pape aille aussi
loin que les évêques de france lors de
leurs déclarations de repentance en
septembre dernier
lundi au vatican on connaîtra l'ampleur
véritable du geste de jean paul ii à
l'égard des juifs
au nord d'israël une bombe a explosé ce
matin dans une station d'autobus à fut
la blessant grièvement une personne
climat de tension qui se poursuit en
cisjordanie
seize palestiniens ont été blessés au
cinquième jour des affrontements avec
l'armée israélienne dans la région
d'hébron affrontements faisant suite à
la mort de trois ouvriers
les soldats ont pris pour cible
apparemment hier des journalistes
palestiniens
l'un d'eux a été blessé par deux balles
la presse étrangère accusent l'armée de
tirer délibérément sur les journalistes
ils ont manifesté à leur manière leur
colère voici ces images
les pilotes de l'avion militaire qui a
provoqué en février l'accident de
téléphérique dans les alpes eux seront
jugés aux états unis washington en effet
refuse de laisser un tribunal italien
sur la sphère les militaires américains
devraient passer devant une cour
martiale
alain de chalvron l'équipage bel et bien
en dessous de 1000 à pied trois
semblèrent altitude minimum autorisé et
dépasser la vitesse maximum de bain de
sang ne 185 kilomètres heure le général
ballon ne mâche pas ses mots
sans les graves erreurs de l'équipage
dit il il n'y aurait pas eu d'accident
là conclut actions dans totem chance
sans circonstances atténuantes dans un
premier temps l'armée américaine avait
tenté de jeter un voile opaque sur
l'accident du 3 février accident qui
avait fait 20 morts à cava les et
lorsqu'un grumman des marines de la base
d'aviano avait arraché le câble d'un
téléphérique et bien aujourd'hui l'armée
américaine fait donc amende honorable
pouvait-elle faire autrement alors que
la télévision italienne avait accusé la
semaine dernière
ces images d'amateurs tourné par
l'équipage d'un grumman dit semblable à
celui qui a provoqué l'accident
on voit l'avion qui rase les montagnes
qui beaucoup dire vol tandis que les que
ce patch moque des habitants de la
vallée qui cumule un réveil en fanfare
l'équipage responsable sera poursuivi en
cour martiale a précisé le colonel quart
d'heure commandant des marines saviano
il faudra aller en prison
mais ses supérieurs directs notamment
les responsables de l'entraînement
auront droit eux aussi à des mesures
disciplinaires pour ne pas avoir fait
respecter les règles et puis on apprend
que de nouveaux officiers américains
chargés de contrôler les vols de l'avion
militaire responsable de l'accident font
l'objet aussi d'une enquête judiciaire
au kosovo quelques dizaines de réfugiés
albanais ont pu regagner leurs villages
sur place ils ont trouvé leur maison
saccagée pour des centaines d'autres
l'exode continue ils sont plus de 600 à
s'entasser dans une école du village
malgré la répression serbe le leader
albanais a décidé de maintenir les
élections prévues pour le 22 mars
prochain en marge des journées
consacrées en france à la grande
vieillesse je vous propose de découvrir
un institut unique au monde
il se trouve à baltimore aux états unis
c'est le premier établissement qui
étudie depuis les années 50 les
phénomènes de vieillissement chez des
bénévoles âgés de 40 à 90 ans maryse
burgot
pas de signe d' hypertension ni de
diabète votre grand mère a vécu jusqu'à
quel âge 101 ans cet américain n'est pas
malade il va pourtant passé trois jours
dans un hôpital à baltimore
edouard franck est involontaire il veut
aider les chercheurs à mieux comprendre
le processus lié l'ismans tous les deux
ans et ce depuis trente ans il vient
donc ici subir une série de tests
médicaux ainsi les changements qui
seront intervenus pendant son
vieillissement sur 50 60 ans ce qui nous
donnera des informations non seulement
sur notre siècle mais aussi sur le
siècle à venir tests psychologiques
évaluation des sens de la densité des os
de la force musculaire de l'amplitude du
souffle 1100 cobayes participe ainsi
aujourd'hui à cette étude unique au
monde qui a commencé en 1958
bien sûr en 40 ans certains volontaires
sont morts d'autres les ont remplacés
mais tous à l'image d'edouard franck
sont animés par la même envie de mieux
comprendre et donc de mieux lutter
contre le vieillissement
ça m'est égal de vieillir ce qui me rend
dingue c'est cette sensation de ralenti
l'étude de ces américains âgés de 40 à
90 ans a permis entre autres de mieux
déceler les premiers signes de maladies
liées à l'âge comme le cancer de la
prostate de mieux comprendre encore le
processus de l'ostéoporose c'est à dire
de la fonte des eaux
les découvertes des chercheurs de
baltimore permettront enfin de mieux
préparer le retour dans l'espace de john
glen en 1962 cet homme fut le premier
américain à tourner en orbite autour de
la terre et dans quelques mois
s'il tient le coup pendant les tests il
retournera dans l'espace mais vous et
ses 78 ans
retour en france un vendredi 13
inoubliable un seul gagnant pour le
deuxième plus gros gain de l'histoire du
lotto en france c'est un habitant du sud
ouest qui va empocher la somme de 100
millions de francs et récupère un
philippe dumas y imprimer dans la nuit
le chèque promotion de 100 millions 80
1791 francs vient tout juste d'arriver
on appelle cela le savoir-faire du faire
savoir et la française des jeux a même
dépêché sur place la photogénie ce gros
lot oublier pour un temps chris gay
réélection le second plus gros gagnant
du loto a validé son bulletin
ici à libourne système flash tirage
aléatoire on a des gens qui aiment ça
qui jouent des gens qu'ils y croient un
vendredi 13 qui porte bonheur de quoi
alimenter le mythe du rêve à la portée
de tous et pousser les gens à jouer
encore et encore le multimillionnaire
girondins ne s'est toujours pas fait
connaître mais nous sommes en mesure de
vous révéler le nom du plus gros
gagnants de ce tirage du loto c'est le
loto 8 même la recette du vendredi 13
avoisine les 270 millions de francs et
ça aussi ça fait rêver
plus de deux millions d'amateurs vont
pouvoir pratiquer la pêche à la truite
ouverture aujourd'hui dans la plupart
des régions de france grâce à un hiver
pluvieux une pêche prometteuse y compris
dans les zones urbaines comme le montre
ce reportage près de strasbourg où une
association avait donné rendez-vous à
ses membres tout ce matin kristin booth
sylvain gauthier
depuis l'aube des milliers de bouchons
sont venu rompre la monotonie des cours
d'eau avec un seul objectif au bout de
l'hameçon la truite
chaque année c'est la même chose
bourgeon rime avec bouchon et
l'ouverture de la pêche à la truite
rené-charles et les autres ne la rate
ray pour rien au monde
en somme c'est un anniversaire pour le
pêcheur un et nous à notre âge à ou
profitent en cause tant que la santé
nous permet de sortir mais c'est dur et
truites relève d'un art difficile d'en
parler jour là des jours comme ça
peut-être après midi en soit il refait
un peu de soleil est nettement mieux
encore ne faut-il pas confondre perche
détruite la bonne taille
c'est le garde-pêche veille
elles sont réglementaires des t3
réglementaire nous avons des pêcheurs
réglementaire mais pas sauvage la truck
car ici comme ailleurs les sociétés de
pêche pratique des nash et de truites
d'élevage avant le jour j
disant que s'il est vrai que vivent les
immersions toutes les semaines mais il
faut aussi un peu de piment pour couper
chaque fois une 2.48 prendre la truite
mais pas à n'importe quel prix
enfin grâce aux gars de pêche les
pêcheurs sont bien gardés mais pyrénées
grâce à leurs particularités
géographiques permettent dans une même
journée de surfer sur l'océan et sur la
neige c'est de là qu'est née une
compétition inédite qui met au défi une
cinquantaine de sportifs tous
professionnel éric perrin emmanuel clair
des surfeurs de mer sur la neige et
surfeurs de neige sur la mer la
quiksilver cup est la seule compétition
en europe où s'affrontent les meilleurs
spécialistes de chacune des disciplines
poudreuse neiges craquante des pyrénées
contre mur d'eau et tubes sans fin dans
l'atlantique à chaque buisson plaisir à
chaque élément sa sensation
answer la chose la plus incroyable c'est
de rentrer dans un tube et d'en sortir
non ça c'est quelque chose
initial c'est une sensation hyper fort
et en snowboard j'irai la vitesse
anglet deuxième jour de compétition le
vent souffle fort suite tempête grêle
mais qu'importe dans le monde
professionnel du surf
on en a vu deux non c'est pas dangereux
veux dire c'est que ces parois il n'y a
pas plus de deux mètres des vagues donc
sa soupe à quoi
quelques kilomètres en autobus plus tard
c'est le soleil de la mongie qui
accueille les compétiteurs 70 cm de
poudreuse des conditions de rêve et la
poudre c'est bien connu le surfeur saada
c'est vraiment grandiose un jour comme
celui-ci je vois fort est vraiment allé
dans la neige fraîche que je perds la
course
et oui au bout mais faut y aller so
virage slalom au coude à coude il faut
descendre pour remonter pour redescendre
dans l'unique espoir de monter cette
fois sur le podium
mer montagne au bout d'un moment avec
sept quick silver cup on finirait
presque par s'y perdre
d'ailleurs je suis assez embêter j'ai
pas mon fort fait remonter pour aller à
la plage demain
c'est le belge et andreï tchmil qui a
remporté aujourd'hui au sprint la 7e
étape du paris nice devant le champion
de france stéphane barthe laurent
jalabert termine troisième c'est la
deuxième victoire consécutive du coureur
belge frank vandenbroucke conserve la
première place au classement général à
la veille de l'arrivée à nice fin des
jeux paralympiques de nagano aujourd'hui
onze jours de compétition pour des
sportifs heureux des sportifs hors du
commun
florilège des moments les plus intenses
christophe duchiron presque trop beau
pour être vrai le bonheur à tomber
contre l'émotion est trop forte et
qu'elle vous jette à terre quand la cour
finit par vous en lasser autour du cou
la médaille et le sourire que vous
espériez presque trop dur pour être vrai
c'est la chute finale des athlètes de l'
international paralympique un cas
exemplaire de dépassement de soi qui
dépasse de loin le handicap
presque trop fou pour être vrai et trop
rapide pour être vraiment raisonnable
les descendeurs qui dévale la pente
comme des malades silva du sport
d'opérette pratiqué par des vrais faux
athlètes c'est du pur spectacle est
facilitée peur et rien que pour ça ça
mérite le respect
les jeunes tricolores andré favre dans
le civil il est ouvrier aux jeux de
nagano il roulait sur leur billet rose
qui font trois fois premier alexandre
brunet pour ses premiers jeux de
médailles d'or une médaille d'argent et
une médaille de bronze par équipes avec
ray de l'ungei bouyoucef les frères
pétard au total 22 médailles pour la
france dont 5 d'or dixième nation sur 32
c'est plus tout à fait ce que c'était
c'est vrai que le niveau a beaucoup
progressé
je dirais qu'il progressera encore parce
que maintenant sur des athlètes de très
haut niveau mais qui vont se spécialiser
à nagano le public c'était l'autre volet
des jeux plus de cent mille spectateurs
en 10 jours de compétition avec une
flamme paralympique
il brillait au fond de leurs yeux cette
place c'est au tac est il là doivent
merci pour eux aux etats unis vente aux
enchères très attendu des objets
ordinaires quotidien ayant appartenu au
président kennedy un événement empreint
de nostalgie à la hauteur de la
popularité du président défunt philippe
gassot la vente de new york devrait être
la dernière qui réunit autant d'objets
personnels du président
l'ultime occasion donc de feuilleter
l'album de famille john fitzgerald
kennedy était sûrement l'homme qui a été
à la fois le plus aimé et le plus haï
d'amérique
ceux qui l'ont adulé trouveront ici des
petits riens qui ont été un moment dans
sa vie des lunettes de soleil par
exemple qui la portait que l'on ajoutait
parce qu'on sait un jour assis dessus
quelqu'un a pensé à les récupérer on est
gêné parfois de retrouver ici une
intimité déshabiller et exposé au tout
venant
on ne nous aura pas épargné le pyjama de
la marque de resto elle bon repos
certains préféreront le cadre il aimait
au large de martha's vineyard près de
cape scott dans le massachussetts avec
ses enfants son voilier et le yacht
seront proposées au public les photos
elles aussi seront vendus ces dessins
griffonnés sur un bloc reflète sa
passion l'homme le plus puissant de la
terre
aimer la mer sur la plage ensoleillée on
misera quelques centaines de dollars
pour la réplique de son bureau et
milliers avec ou sans les drapeau qui
ornait le bureau ovale de la maison
blanche ses objets viennent de 70
personnes beaucoup étaient soit des
proches du président ou des membres de
son administration
ou alors simplement des valets des
chauffeurs qui d'une manière ou d'une
autre était en relation avec lui on va
trouver c'est rock in chair dans les
objets convoités la montre en or offerte
par jacky elle il ne la quittait jamais
pas plus que cette serviette qu'il a
toujours conservé
elle a transporté tous ses secrets
d'état et aussi les autres suite des
défilés du prêt-à-porter avec christian
lacroix et gauthier qui tous les deux se
sont inspirés des années d'après-guerre
tous les deux se sont assagis et puis
fidèle à ses recherches gnac et continue
de jouer sur les matières se fumer elle
bruno livertout maquillage à peine
esquissés teint de porcelaine
un hommage depuis six ans la croix au
paris de l'après-guerre à ces femmes
courageuses assez résistante disparu ou
presque les superpositions ses
patchworks frénétique la silhouette
c'est pure pour laisser vivre plus
encore la matière est là mais par
exemple et réimprimé avec de l'or pour
avoir toujours cet effet de dégradé qui
est présent dans toute la toute la
collection
et puis des effets par contre tout à
fait industriel métisse où la lumière
joue comme une broderie couture est en
fait sont de toutes petites touches de
choses de deux démenti comme de toreros
veuf sylviane puis sur la preuve depuis
l'est pas non plus résisté à ses amours
qui lui colle à la peau
loi de jazz le saint germain des prés
des existentialistes curieusement ce
sont ces mêmes années d'après-guerre qui
ont inspiré gauthier le vêtements larges
et confortables d'égal faussement
négligée il entraîne ses intellectuels
de galeries d'art en bistrot à la botte
touche de folklore le ba-ba avant
l'heure en bonnet péruvien mais
l'exubérance n'est plus de mise
gauthier a rangé ses jouets d'enfant
terrible reste l'énergie et surtout
l'élégance aucune nostalgie chez issey
miyake mais une recherche incessante de
modernité par la matière ou lyonnais de
nylon une femme écorces d'arbre à
croiser au fond des bois chrysalide doré
à l'or fin entre couvertures de survie
est tenu a perfé l'ère des chemins
inexplorés où seul le japonais osseux
hasard
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres 80 de
réclusion pour le jeune alexis la cour
d'assises reconnaît sa culpabilité mais
ce verdict très en-deça du réquisitoire
une mitigé insatisfaisant selon la
défense
demain élections régionales et
cantonales près de 39 millions
d'électeurs appelés aux urnes mode
d'emploi de ce scrutin à un seul tour
pour les régionales et à deux tours pour
les cantonales dans un instant la météo
présentée par patrice drevet 20h50
fiesta l'émission présentée par patrick
sébastien suivi à 23h15 du magazine
présenté par christophe dechavanne du
fer dans les épinards demain matin dans
thé ou café
catherine ceylac recevra jacques
lanzmann pour son roman la mémoire des
dieux je vous retrouve pour ma part
demain exceptionnellement à 19h15 début
de cette grande soirée consacrée aux
résultats des élections
merci de votre attention excellente fin
de soirée sur france 2
c'est